we have robert pattinson right here uh
from an outtake of their film
obviously hey robert
hey brendan hey theo matthew coming at
you from montreal canada
here for some sex advice uh-oh here we
go
so lately in the last three years i've
hadn't had sex
once and i'm finding it a little bit
concerning
maybe a little honorable but honor i'm
just
i've hit a rough patch lately i'm just
i'm working all the time
i'm a plumber full-time so it's it
doesn't really go well
with the whole schedule of just going
out and meeting new people but
i'd like to know your thoughts on this
um gang gang buzz buzz
um one part of this on a playground
one part yeah it's kind of scary you
guys obviously donated most of his blood
too
yeah there's but he's really handsome to
not be [ __ ] for three years yeah he's
not a bad
dude which immediately makes me think is
he at us just to get laid
because it's just this guy's actually
really active and he just figured oh
this is another way to get laid with
with uh
you know well yeah he's going to sneak
outside of somewhere to make them
go to a playground is it a playground
yeah there's a playground behind them
in one of the dopest cities ever
montreal is the dopest place like
i would not be on a playground i'd be at
some poutine bar getting [ __ ]
hot montreal poontang okay sure come out
of a window in montreal it'll land on
somebody
somewhere insanely high so here's the
deal he's got he's got to re-prioritize
right
first of all you don't know how old he
is i'm assuming he's an adult right yeah
i mean sometimes you know 15 year olds
look like very
he's a plumber though yeah he's that's
what i'm saying he's a plumber full-time
and
the plumbers are beautiful this guy's i
know one of the best party speaks two
languages
i forgot to say get it re-prioritize set
sometime aside it's that simple but make
it i mean he's got in these
days when you have apps yes there's a
million apps dude but it sounds like he
said he almost felt like
a happy or not proud or proud of it
honorable so maybe there's some like
thing going on like a religious thing
yeah like he feels like he should be
like he's an incel or something or you
know that he has some issues
around maintaining abstinence but bottom
line is balance is important
balance your life not don't not just the
workaholism
put time aside to socialize he'll be
fine and i'm assuming he's a plumber
that's a monday through friday gig
saturday and sunday the apps too yeah
but you can see how if somebody really
wanted to succeed they could they could
be plumbing 16 hours ago that's what i
used to tell that to drew's son he has
triplets and two of them are
boys and they of course like any young
20 you know in their early 20s they're
concerned about [ __ ]
and i would talk about i was like dude
honestly
if your 20s through like your 20s and
early 30s suck
that's probably a good thing it's the
guys i worry about are
constantly clubbing well past college
age they're not setting up their life
you
i said really make sure that these years
suck
because when you're 40 life's gonna be
[ __ ] awesome yeah and you're gonna
have money
and and a sense of self and you're gonna
be confident and you're just gonna
they'll be [ __ ] falling off of walls
and hitting you you could do both though
right i think there's a balance there to
drew's point i think you could do both
yeah you set your life up there's a
still they need a visit from uncle mike
we need a little
little chat that sounded gross kiddos do
that yeah
they need to look pep talk they need a
little how old are they now
this cover thing has been rough on that
late twenties oh yeah
really do anything a lot of people are a
youtuber throwing parties they can't go
anywhere
jerking off a lot of men pretending gay
you know doing everything like that
you should write children's books for
adults mike that would be
nothing creepy about that well we need
them though i feel like i think you're
[Music]
right
[Music]
is